welcome back to the David Pakman show.
I am Farron cousins from ring of fire sitting
in for David [inaudible].
Amen.
Today, I'm very sad story.
Yesterday announced a 16 year old Guatemalan
migrant died while in the custody of Border
Patrol at a detention facility, 16 years old.
So another minor in this marks the fifth minor
to die in custody of border patrol since December.
So six months, five deaths, all minors.
So my question now is, where are all those
pro lifers where all those people touting
the Alabama abortion ban the Georgia abortion
ban, saying that we are protecting the lives
of children.
We care so much about children and will do
anything to protect them.
Okay.
What about the ones who are literally dropping
dead in these detention facilities along our
southern border?
Where's your concern for them?
Those are kids who've been alive, living their
lives, some separated from their parents,
and they just died because of the lack of
care, the horrid conditions and the horrid
conditions that they tried to escape.
There seems to be no concern among Republicans
for these children, and it's because the Republicans
are not actually a pro life party.
They're a pro controlling women party.
They don't care about life whatsoever.
Once a child is born, they're concern is over.
They don't care about them.
And I think that's the big point.
We always have to hammer when we talk about
these show called pro lifers, because sending
our children, sending anyone of any age off
to a war based on lies to die, that's not
prolife.
Okay.
Letting migrant children drop dead in border
patrol custody, that's not prolife starving
medicaid of money so that poor children in
this country can't get medical care and end
up dying as a result.
Yeah, that's not prolife either.
Pro Life is taken care of every single person
that is living and breathing, that's literally
prolife, but that is not what Republicans
are.
And at the same time that they're ignoring
these very real problems in this country.
They're telling us the Democrats are the ones
who hate children.
Democrats are the ones who want to kill children.
They're the party of death.
They're pro death is what they're telling
us.
There's certainly is a political party that
appears to be pro death, but I can promise
you it isn't the Democratic Party and other
equally depressing news this week, and we're
still so very early in the week, and that's
what makes it even more depressing.